شغب في بروكسل بعد مباراه المغرب وبلجيكا
والده اشرف حكيمي تشعل السوشيال ميديا
ولماذا رفضت شابي تدريب البرازيل في كاس
العالم هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على
العربيه رياضه
التي عمت الشوارع الرئيسيه فيها بعد فوز
المنتخب المغربي التاريخي على نظيره
البلجيكي بهدفين دون رد ضمن منافسات
المجموعه السادسه من مونديال قطر ففي
مشاهد رصدتها عدسات الكاميرا مباشره بعد
انتهاء بعد نهايه المباراه ونقلتها مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ظهرت سيارات مقلوبه
ومحترقه ومفرقعات ناريه وبحسب الانباء
المشهوره هاجم عشرات الاشخاص ام لا كان
عامه وعناصره امن وجرى استخدامه وفرقعات
والقائه مقذوفات فيما تسلل بعض بيعصيا
اخرون حريقه في الطريق العام
ومع المونديال نبقى حيث اشعلت لقطه توجه
اشرف حكيمي لوالدته التي كانت في المدرجات
وتقبيله لراسها السوشيال ميديا لاعب باريس
سان جيرمان فرنسي احتضن في مشهد جميل
ومؤثر والدته التي تواجدت في المدرجات
لمؤازره نجلها ومنتخب اسود الاطلس امام
بلجيكا وظهر اشرف حكيمي بعدها برفقه
والدته بعد انتهاء المباراه التاريخيه
محتفلا معها بالفوز على طريقته الخاصه
نتحاول ان الى التشابي مدرب برشلونه
الاسباني الذي اكد حصوله على عرضا للتدريب
المنتخب البرازيلي لكره القدم واشارت شعبي
في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان العرض قدم من قبل
رئيس الاتحاد البرازيلي لكره القدم مؤكدا
ايضا انهم جاءوا الى قطر وسالوه اذا كان
من الممكن ان يصبح جزء من الجهاز الفني
تحت قياده تيتي الا ان تشافي رفض العرض
بحسب قوله رغبه منه بقيادته برشلونه
الاسباني
الختام مع لوحه الفنيه المرسومه على واق
الساق الخاص بالجاكو لاعب المنتخب
الياباني هذه الرسمه لافتات انظار عدسات
الكاميرا التي التقطتها على اهم شي مباراه
اليابان وكوستاريكا في مونديال قطر وحقق
المنتخب الكوستركي فوزا على اليابان بهدف
دون رد ضمن منافسات المجموعه الخامسه من
مونديال 2002 2020
[موسيقى]